today on Gareth learn things we're going
to learn about goat yoga now this is
Fusion you know you see a lot of people
like mixing kinds of food together like
Asian Cuisine and Mexican that's sort of
today with goats and the ancient art of
yoga now I don't know why they haven't
like fused other exercises like you know
like cougar CrossFit or like horse
Pilates but for some reason this one is
supposed to be fantastic so let's figure
out why
foreign
so how did this all start how like
because yoga is something that's been on
going around for a while goats have been
on Earth for a while how did these two
combine what happens it's a great
question and it's a good story you hear
that it's a great question
um not surprisingly it started up in
Oregon sure
um and pretty recently 2016. okay
there's a lady named Laney Morse and she
had some goats she was kind of I love
this story already she had goats she's
like she's not gonna do yoga in the pen
she invited some some of her friends
over one of whom was a yoga teacher okay
so they started just doing some yoga for
healing and emotional health and the
goats started jumping up on them and
they decided to turn it into a thing you
have to have really good friends to be
like hey I I'm just hanging out with the
goats I'm like let's do yoga with the
goat goats are natural climbers because
they're prey animals they prefer to be
as high as possible same here by the way
you're a prey animal no no I like to be
as high as possible okay because they're
natural climbers as they jump on you and
they're trying to find their footing as
they would on a mountain let's say they
tend to find those deep pesky knots sure
um so I'm often telling people that you
might fire your massage therapist in
favor of a goat because it feels can't
give them that reason though you have to
be like I don't can't afford it you
can't be like I found a goat take care
later I feel like the goat
assistant stretching and the core I feel
like it's so different yeah no
stretching when you're strengthening
okay sure okay when you're in a plank
pose a tabletop your body will naturally
recruit certain core muscles sure but
when it experiences an unexpected load
such as a goat sure
um it recruits extra muscles to actually
hold you stable so you'll you'll feel
stronger and and I warn people that once
you've done a plank with a goat you
probably don't want to do a plank
without a goat again what is the worst
part to the fusion of goats and yoga
because I have a guess
my guess would be the constant
my guess would be that like people like
this is great but then the second a goat
shits on your hand or your mat you're
like this is I mean there's a downside
have you ever seen goat poo yeah no I
love the stuff yeah so it's butt raisins
I love it I'm way into it it looks like
Junior Mints yeah do humans ever feel
like that's contagious and then some
guys just like I want to piss on my mat
you're like sir this is you know
society's rules this is not okay and
clearly not no okay all right does
anyone wear like an anorak or like a
poncho to class do the people who get
pissed on come back yeah they do do you
think it's because they're like oh man I
haven't been able to feel that good
since I go pissed all in my back nothing
like gopis going down your butt crack
when you're at a plane thank you I'm
excited to do some goat yoga I'm excited
for you to do goat yoga um and then if
they poop on me and uh I'm hoping they
do we call it blessings blessings what
an interesting way of putting it
[Applause]
[Music]
be ready for laughter it's a super chill
class I know you're here for the goats
and not for me so feel free to do as
much yoga or as little yoga as you want
I will not be offended you could take
play breaks no problem absolutely you
can just sit there if you feel like
sitting there and just petting a goat
the entire class I'm completely fine
with that okay what we're going to do is
we're going to do a communal bot to let
the goats know we're ready and make them
feel something's happening to my back
pharah one of them's fighting me you're
gonna take a deep breath in
and exhale with a big long bob
I think you guys can do better than that
let's try again inhale I was distracted
they're killing Luke
they will be interacting with you in
ways you may not expect they have no
boundaries okay be ready for anything
really they don't they're not shy about
the back stuff no I'm glad we got those
gloves on the hooks
come back to a seated position inhale
both arms up oh boy
it's weird when it's just a yoga pose at
this point you feel like cheated uh that
well I'd certainly feel some pressure on
the stretch
that's go yoga benefit number two
I thought you yoga benefit number two is
the blessings
oh boy sometimes it does feel a little
coming at you
like one of the goats has maybe lost
interest in the class a little bit
because they found the shrub
she'll come back okay will entice there
very nicely done
take a couple of breaths here
hello
I was attacked by a group of goats
the group of goats just attacked me
now does if someone gets blessed do they
win anything like a new mat
um this is where I feel like it gets
exciting
um
the night in the drug tank
we specifically avoid um front up I
would I would I would guess that's a
good cheese sauce
hello I feel like a centaur hello all
right let's do a little cat and a little
cow there oh right there is where I hold
a lot of tension there you go give it to
him Ivy thank you Ivy take it out for
you thank you Ivy you're my best friend
Ivy oh I I get it blessed I got blast
Ed
I got blessed on
I got blessed all over I think some of I
think some of the blessings went in my
pants
unless I blessed myself after the
blessing I was gonna say I don't know
how you're wearing your pants for the
blessings to go in your pants thank you
very much
I'm truly blessed what an honor this is
Donna our goat Grandma she's taking care
of the blessings now I'm gonna say it
makes moving a little more precarious
when it comes to the positions now this
is called downward facing sweep
I mean I've really at least I know what
I'm not into now oh I don't know you
seem pretty into it am I the toilet of
the class is that well this is just this
is just one we'll see if they go again
on you I really hope that I've maxed out
oh that's fine it just touched my hand
and that's fine it's just vegan
blessings vegan blessings
we should bottle it up and sell it as
fertilizer I don't know about that
go to Liza yeah uh-huh and where do you
guys sell new mats is that around here
just kick standing it behind you holding
yourself steady don't kick a go there's
still a lot of blessings around me are
we do we just kind of quit on the
blessing cleaning oh or go under hey
double team oh my lord well done I've
really if I were a PornHub search today
I'd really have all the searches
now does anyone ever get rammed in their
uh you know no no okay never heard it
blessings see what happened in front
like well behind you not on you well I
mean yeah well I guess it's a minor win
that way good news the goats didn't
down your pants anymore they like you I
don't think that's how it works
I saw the goat tunnel you got this ivy
for what
yeah be ready be ready Gareth is there
how am I supposed to be ready for a goat
to jump on my back we have a signature
goat pose are you guys ready for it sure
okay it's called goat in a boat
if you're feeling a little more lazy
today you can just do regular boat or
lazy boat where you're not holding
yourself up and if you're really lazy
today just do raft
so pick your boat the goats will come in
your boat oh no coco I never wanted a
goat to come in my boat that's the Dr
Seuss they never released
the goats come in my boat
this is called goat in a boat oh sorry
but they'll come in your boat well not
with my mother around oh
rafting I can't put my face down because
a goat earlier defecated on my raft
blessed sorry
hard to think of anything from yesterday
or tomorrow while there's goats running
amok
so enjoy that time your spirit got to
just be
or just
look at me oh my god
um
literally fighting over you Garrett well
that's nice it's been a while
by two ladies no nonetheless oh then
that's never happened
I will say this is unlike anything I
thought it would be like good it is
really quite different we take that as a
compliment as you should I mean it is
one
you're going to inhale all this good
love and light and energy and we will
exhale with a big long Camino Bama stay
oh last day
wow good job yogis well done
well we've got some footage hello
oh more blessings
it's truly been a Pious experience what
did we learn today well I think we
learned that not all Fusion is fantastic
but sometimes risks pay off
I think we learned that goat yoga is
actually great as far as stretching and
I think that we learned that it's better
to your pants than have a goat
them
[Music]